as you all know i am but a humble and
shy podcaster there's nothing
i hate more than attention especially
attention from my ideological
adversaries i find it quite frightening
to be confronted by them sure i may have
a funny way of showing it sometimes like
at st louis university where we went
outside to confront the mob of angry
protesters to their face or at loudoun
county where we rented a woman's
basement just so that we could go and
yell at the local school board you might
see something like that and think that i
enjoy this kind of thing or even that i
thrive on it but that's a
misinterpretation i am meek and bashful
on the inside and that's why
i was so distressed to hear that lgbt
activists are planning a major protest
at my event at texas a m tomorrow
now being such a self-effacing person i
simply i i just hate it when the left
makes a scene at my events bringing more
attention to my message and to me and
putting me in the headlines and so on
it's it's terrible
i wish they
wouldn't do it i begged them to stop but
they just won't listen
and so it was with great horror that i
was made aware of the plot they have
concocted for tomorrow some informants
over at
yaf sent me internal documents
where the protesters have helpfully laid
out their plan point by point
and even describe ahead of time the
disguises they'll be wearing in order to
get into the event indeed their plan is
to infiltrate the event from the inside
disrupt it shout me down and generally
cause a big scene
and again
i hate big scenes it's the thing i hate
the most don't be fooled by the fact
that i go out of my way to put myself in
the middle of such scenes sometimes
risking my own physical safety to do so
still i i hate it and that's why i'm
begging the leftist activists not to
carry out this plan
please do not bring more publicity to my
event
and to me into the message that i have
uh please i'm asking for your mercy
don't do it
now referring to the document titled
layout of the walkout
it begins with step one which is to
reserve a ticket to the event
uh which are free by the way and anyone
can get a ticket they want to claim as
many tickets for themselves as they can
ahead of time in order to prevent people
who actually want to listen to the talk
from being able to do so and then it
continues quote unquote
step two
show up at msc beth and court ballroom
on wednesday february 9th at 5 p.m
wearing business casual or business
formal clothing
arriving early gives us time to form
groups and ensures that our members can
reserve as many seats as possible before
walsh's supporters
business casual allows us to blend in
with walsh's supporters and should be
done in addition to dressing cisgender
and heterosexual passing
if you're questioned or draw attention
due to your voice appearance or gender
presentation explain that you're
attending the talk to earn credit for a
political science or philosophy class
now uh i have to say that i'm glad these
people will be dressing appropriately
for once so that's nice though i do find
it a little bit funny that they think my
supporters all walk around in business
casual or business formal attire i don't
even dress that way to my own events
i'll be there in a flannel
i'm also quite interested in this plan
to dress cisgender or heterosexual
passing
i guess that leaves me i guess that
means leave the the fishnet and assless
chaps at home offer the best i suppose
in fact just because i'm a generous
person
i will actually try to help
these activists
i'm going to help you
if you're planning to infiltrate my
event
and you want to blend in with cisgender
and heterosexual passing clothing all
you have to do
is wear white t-shirts with i'm a
heterosexual in big red letters across
the front that's the best way to blend
in that's how all that's how we
heterosexuals dress it's just what we do
it's how we identify other members of
our tribe
and we oftentimes will go up to someone
and say hey bro you hetero
and then they'll open up their jacket to
show the t-shirt and we'll fist bump and
say hell yeah hetero for life
in fact make sure to do that at the
event exactly that
um while you're kind of mingling with
the crowd
what you could do is just walk up to
people and say hey fellas just doing my
cisgender hetero thing what about you
and when everyone hears that they're
going to know that you're one of us
also one other quick tip
oftentimes we'll wear clown noses
just a big bright red clown noses
so make sure to wear them as well
and a wig also wouldn't hurt
although i suppose the clown wig might
be indistinguishable from your usual
hairstyle so just just the nose will be
fine glad i can help now back to the
document it says if you bring a bag or
purse the bag will be searched if you're
bringing a speaker or flag you must
conceal the speaker flag somewhere on
your body
now pausing here again
and i don't want to
use my imagination too much here but
i'm not sure i want to know how these
people plan to conceal a speaker or flag
on their body i don't want to know
which crevice or orifice will be used
for for storage in this case
but i guess this is another reason why
fishnets and asylus chaps are out of the
question if you feel like you are
getting the respect you deserve in life
well i've got a solution for you
establish titles is your opportunity to
earn the title of lord or lady and gain
the respect you deserve all you need is
a one square foot plot of land in
scotland in your title pack you'll
receive at least one square foot of
dedicated land on a private estate and
an official certificate with the crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land these title
packs are a fantastic gift and the best
way to surprise your loved ones from
girlfriends of boyfriends or even family
you could even get a couple pack for you
and your partner where you can get
adjoining plots of land
well with this certificate you could
officially change your name to lord or
lady and get it on your credit card your
plane ticket etc
establish titles as having a great
extended new year's sale so go to
establishtitles.com matt walsh to save
10 off today and remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established titles
dot com slash matt walsh or just click
the link below continuing it says
step three find our chanter and members
with portable speakers and break into
groups of nine if you're not in the
group find a buddy we'll have one person
leading chance and at least two members
with portable speakers to announce the
start of the walkout each of these
people must be in groups of nine so that
their groups can be arranged in seats
surrounding them for safety like so and
you can see the uh
the chart they have set up they've got
everything in a color coordinated chart
which looks like they're playing
battleship or something the document
also notes that if they can't get 35
protesters to show up they'll surrender
and disband
and it's kind of sad to think of these
poor people all showing up in their
heterosexual outfits and then doing a
head count and finding out that there's
out no only 27
so they just turn around and walk away
awkwardly if we see a bunch of people in
clown noses wandering away dejectedly
we'll know what happened
the document goes on with step four
explaining how they'll coordinate their
seating chart and then step five which
says quote wait for the recording to
play put your mask on stand up and raise
your left fist after 10 to 20 minutes of
walsh speaking enough time for any
overflow crowd outside the room to
disperse so they cannot take our place
when we leave a recording of the star
manifesto will be played over the
speakers star stands for street
transvestite action revolutionaries and
was the group founded by marsha p
johnson and silvia rivera to support
homeless and incarcerated trans people
during the gay liberation movement once
the recording plays if you aren't
already wearing a covet mask please put
one on so that your face is
unrecognizable stand up and raise your
left fist
what a shocker here
they plan to wear a mask not because
they actually think it will protect them
from covin but just to conceal their
identity while they cause a public
disruption
if i didn't know any better i might
think that all of the shoplifters and
looters in blue cities across the
country are are wearing masks for the
same reason
which is really a revelation because up
until now i just assumed that they were
all very health conscious
in any case we get finally to step six
where the chanting begins and protesters
are encouraged to take a screenshot of
the chant lyrics so that they don't
forget the words so they're all gonna
pull out their phones they're gonna have
the lyrics there they're gonna start
chanting
and i might have to put this up on the
chalkboard for them in the room uh just
to make it easier
um but the chant goes as follows you
have the first you have the the leader
who will say when trans people are under
attack what do we do and the crowd
responds stand up fight back
then repeats gay and queer in place of
trans
i'd say i'm a little disappointed in the
chant because it doesn't rhyme
any good chant should always rhyme
especially in this case when a very
simple edit would solve the problem
far be it for me to offer notes to the
people who are trying to shout me down
at my own event but why wouldn't the
chant be
when trans people are under attack stand
up fight back
what we you don't need what do we do
just attack them back it rhymes
much better
pithier has a better flow it rhymes
anyway if all goes according to plan
they will stage this demonstration about
10 to 20 minutes into my talk cause
several minutes of disruption and then
walk out
and we'll just resume the event as
scheduled
and then because they caused the scene
and turned the speaking event into a
news event
i will afterwards be forced to do
several local and cable news interviews
where i talk about the event
and also the subject i was there to
speak about thereby amplifying the very
message they were trying to shut down
and we certainly wouldn't want that
you know it almost might seem as though
the truth shines brighter
the more you try to suppress it
and and you might even think
that the better approach for an opponent
would be to engage with my message
intellectually
actually try to debate my points
which they could do during the q a
in fact not only can they do it during
the q a but if you disagree you get to
go to the front of the line
that's how much you are welcome and you
get a microphone or you can say whatever
you want
and and
given that i'm just a i'm just a
drooling
stupid
uh
racist homophobic
fascist bigots
it should be really easy to embarrass me
i didn't even go to college these are
all college students they have more
education than i do
officially anyway
so why wouldn't you take the opportunity
to take the microphone and just
totally humiliate me
tear me apart
i'll have just finished speaking for 30
minutes and you could go point by point
boom boom boom and rip it apart
problem is it's hard to do that
if your whole world view is empty and
vacuous and built atop a house of cards
that collapses under the slightest
intellectual scrutiny
i suppose your only choice then is to
chant and scream
and run away
plugging your ears
so good luck with that
i'll see you tomorrow
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated